hi this is a 2013 Nissan Altima I'm
going to program the key there's key
security sign flashing I have the new
key fob here which is smart key goal
Nissan system type smart key one
go keyless go adapt Achilles no pincode
turn them in the emergency switch on yes
programming with 56 seconds
the ping code reader will read the ping
code
okay I got a ping code and press yes
don't step on the brakes keep pressing
start button until the ignition on okay
ignition is on
turn the engine off its off use the
first keyless top click start button
then release
okay the key working lock unlock lock
unlock the key registration complete so
press the button it starts the vehicle
the key is programmed